- [Voiceover] Let f of
x equal a times x to n
plus b x plus 12
over c times x to the m
plus d x plus 12
where m and n are integers
and a, b, c and d are
unknown constants are.
This is interesting.
Which of the following is a possible graph
of y is equal to f of x?
And it tells us the dashed
lines indicate asymptotes.
So they gave us four choices here.
And so I encourage you like always.
Pause this video.
Give a go at it.
See if you can figure
out which of these graphs
could be the graph for y equals f of x
where f of x, where they've given us
this information about f of x.
All right, now let's
work to this together.
Now this is really interesting.
It's, you know, they didn't give us a lot.
They didn't even tell us
what the exponents on x are.
They haven't even given
us the coefficients.
All they've told us is this 12 here.
So this 12 looks like a pretty big clue.
So what can that tell us?
The way they've written that
we really can't deduce any
zeros for the function.
We really can't deduce what x values
make the numerator equals zero
or what x values make the
denominator equal zero.
So it's gonna be hard for us to deduce
what are the zeros of the function
or what are the removable discontinuities
or what are the vertical asymptotes.
But just these 12 sitting
here does tell us one thing.
What happens when x equals zero?
Because when x equal
zero, every other term
in this rational expression is
just going to be equal to zero.
And so we can figure out f of zero.
F of zero is going to be equal to,
well a times zero to the n,
well that's just going to be a zero
plus b times zero.
Well, that's just going to be zero.
Plus 12 over
c times zero to the m power.
Well, that's just going to be zero.
D times zero is going to be a zero.
And then we have our 12 there.
So we're actually able to figure out
what f of zero is.
It's 12 over 12
or one.
So we actually know the y
intercept for this function.
Let's see if that's enough information
for us to figure out
if any of these choices
could be the graph of y equals f of x.
So let's see here.
So choice a, our y intercept is a two.
When x equals zero, our graph goes to two.
So we can rule that out.
The y intercept needs to be one.
So we can rule out, let's see, choice B
does have a y intercept.
It looks just eyeballing it at one,
x equals zero, y is one.
So this looks interesting.
Choice C has its y intercept
at y is equal to negative one.
So once again, we can rule that out.
And choice D has no y-intercept at all.
So that was enough information.
And lucky for us because
they really didn't give us
a lot more information than just
what be able to evaluate f of zero.
We were able to figure
out any of the other,
you know, the zeros or
the vertical asymptotes
or their removable discontinuities.
So we definitely feel
good about that choice.